how do I translate a website using
Google Cloud
so you've got yourself a really fancy
Global website but now you gotta make
sure it speaks the language of every
nook and cranny on this big old Planet
how in the world are you supposed to do
that without going crazy well
try hiring a bunch of translators but
that's gonna cost you a pretty penny
specially if you want to cover every
language Under the Sun or you can make
your developers do it but then you're on
the risk of them getting sidetracked and
forgetting to do more important stuff
but fear not my friends there is an
easier way to get the job done just use
translate API stick all your static
content in cloud storage bucket and boom
it'll be cached and accessible faster
than you can say
internationalization want to learn more
check out the links in the comments
section